what's going on guys you know there are
two seasons that I'm extremely excited
about bikini season and summer movie
season today we're talking summer box
office and we have three movie
aficionados to break it down for us
first you know him from the schmoes know
and AMC movie talk mr. Kristian harloff
had you back here this time I got to try
to win she is lovely and delightful one
of the hosts of clever movies Aaron
Robinson and you're in luck because
bikini season and summer season are the
same season how this mofo was a badass
he's the head badass at badass digest
Devin Faraci and you're in luck because
I'm wearing a bikini oh that's for the
too hot for the internet screen gelatin
screen junkies after dark okay so before
we break down what we think the top
grossing films of the sum are going to
be let's just talk about the summer yeah
what are we looking forward to what are
we thinking oh I'm not sure about that
dawn of the Planet yes this is my number
one film of the house on the leaded out
I am beyond psyched if some horses even
now will the Apes on horses beat the
Transformers on Dinobots but my most
anticipated movie of the summer of my
forest guardians of the galaxy guardians
of the galaxy is like a film that we
haven't seen yet by Marvel and I think
it'll be a little bit challenging to get
the fans to really go out and be
confident in seeing it
maybe general audiences moreso than the
fans is this too much of a gamble for
Marvel or is it gonna pay off no there's
a table playing with unlimited chips
ain't no I did another doing you know
what I was talking to a guy from Marvel
and he know there was like this moment
where we had no BS and he said this is
the best script we've ever had this is a
great script is there a movie that
you're kind of rooting for this summer
Godzilla yeah like Godzilla for me is
the movie I cannot wait the trailers
have gotten me excited and I hope if it
does well like Bevin said before it's
gonna crack the top 10 for sure but if
it stinks that's the end of Godzilla
okay so let's talk box office we each
made top-10 lists our predictions let's
take a look at everybody's lists here's
Christians list as we can see is Dark
Horse's Maleficent and
a me at nine and ten and he's the lowest
on guardians putting it at seven
here's Aaron's list she's one of only
two people to have the Ninja Turtles on
her list and she's the only one not to
pick transformers at number one going
with spider-man
- here's Devin's list he's the only one
to have edge of tomorrow on his list
having it at number eight and he's the
lowest on x-men days of future past and
putting it all the way down at number
seven here's my list you know the best
one I have three comedies on my list
starting with a million ways to die in
the West at number 10 and I'm the
highest on How to Train Your Dragon 2
putting it at number 2 Christian I'm
looking at your list one movie that you
and I both have in the top 10 Devin and
Aaron do not put it in there
Tammi Melissa McCarthy is a juggernaut
you have to hit at least 150 million
dollars to be in this if it delivers and
it's funny the word of mouth spreads
this movie can easily hit top 10 guys
why the why the McCarthy hate why are
you a couple of Rex wreaths down no I
love Melissa McCarthy I thought the heat
was one of the best movies of the summer
last year I just don't think it'll be as
big as some of my other contenders it
was it would make my top 15 for sure
there is a female audience that I think
that often gets overlooked and that's
been the key to her success so far but I
really suspect that this one's gonna be
a little bit boring
I think the pitch Devon was like okay
what if we put the heat in a KFC trainer
dragon number 4 why did that make your
list the first one was very successful
people loved that movie people loved
that score just the music alone people
listen to that it's not only bringing
the the family on us is gonna bring in
people who just love animation it's it's
gonna be a big hit and I think it'll
definitely crack top 5 I'm hoping it's
for you don't have a despicable me or a
Toy Story this summer How to Train Your
Dragon fills that void and there's
always one of those movies that blows up
does I have it number 2 on my list yeah
you know I didn't put on my list I
regret it now people do love the first
movie there's a lot of warmth towards it
and I think that I think there's got a
really good chance of doing really well
and thus making me lose this whole
goddamn you
and parents are going to want to have
get their kids out of the house and
there are only a few movies they can do
that this summer with and this is going
to be the one that they send their kids
do son-of-a-gun
cool let's take a look at Aaron's list I
have to defend my spider-man is number
one I made a prediction last year that
if that I thought the amazing spider-man
2 would be the highest-grossing movie of
the summer and if I lost that bet I
would read a new story in a bikini
please take your dogs take your friends
take your stuffed animals to see the
amazing counterpoint to the Nazi amazing
swagger
hence his favorite student of the year
that's why the amazing spider-man I was
in my number one but I mean it's got a
great position it always a damage in the
Iron Man position from last year and
this may spot has done well for Sony in
the past so I feel like it's gonna be
huge it's bringing in so many of these
new villains some of the better villains
in the spider-man universe in my opinion
the action in the trailer kind of
excites me I think you were in a bikini
because yeah the same problem they have
the first movie they have shown us the
entire goddamn moon I know and that you
have already seen the whole movie and
there is a sense of people of being sick
of this picture already cool let's take
a look at Devin's list let's talk about
your number one transformers yeah I
think it's the obvious number one film
in the summer I mean whether or not is
garbage everybody's gonna go see it it's
got the Dinobots I mean he's a really
smart decision Africa everybody who
watches the trailer says I know this is
gonna be terrible but it's got the
DynaVox yeah that's it I'm that guy one
movie that's not on my list or
Christians list but you both have TMNT
talked to us about the turtles okay
first of all every single person who
knows who the Ninja Turtles are are
going to go see this movie regardless of
if Michael Bay produced it regardless of
what the trailers look like we're going
to go because it's a teenager you Ninja
Turtle movie and we love the teams we
Ninja Turtles they're not making it for
30 something's you grow up in the
cartoon they're making it for 9 year old
kids right now that is a strong
demographic a lot of the movies that are
coming out this summer are harder-edged
or darker this is going to be a movie
that's going to have fun wisecracking
Turtles in that mold they're yelling
Cowabunga and stuff and they're silly
and it's going to be there hoping it's
going to be PG there's only one movie in
August that is going to make the top 10
B's that's hard that's
audience and that's Guardian Guardians
is going a little maternal i'm not
underestimate i think it's gonna do well
i just think people are gonna still be
seeing guardians during the time Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles comes out and I
think that that overlap will chop some
of that I totally agree that it's for
kids I think that that's going you're
gonna get your majority money from the
kids but it's not hitting talk time I
have three comedies on my list I have a
million ways to die in the West which no
one has that's my number ten movie you
know what comedy I miss that I think
could sneak in there that I'm probably
in regret not putting in there is
neighbors neighbors the stinking ever
and what did you think it's great really
that's all I hear like all I hear is
funny yeah it's really you know and I
mean not to get like too lame but it's
generally well structured and Zac Efron
is in what really da I belly about is
redefining his whole career yeah like
you will walk out of this movie and you
will go Zac Efron can can act Deven let
me throw it down to you you have
Guardians higher than anybody here you
have it number two on your list well I'm
a bad at this game uh that's the first
thing we have to specify even though we
know nothing about Star Wars now when it
begins filming in May we're gonna begin
getting stuff and I think that Guardians
is gonna have that vibe that I like
about the original Star Wars yeah it's
got a han Solo in it and I think I think
I'm gonna go you know I'm really getting
excited about Star Wars again and this
movie is gonna scratch that itch until
next year okay I'm gonna throw this out
to everybody what would be the one thing
this summer that would just make your
jaw drop kinda long the lines of Lone
Ranger being such a mega flop last year
I think of Transformers bombed does it
have the potential bombing probably not
but then maybe it is if the crabbers
just like no we've seen all three we
don't want to see it anymore
mmm that's highly unlikely but if that
happened I'd be like I couldn't if
transformers bombs it is sort of one of
those things that can make everybody who
works in the industry start trying to
figure out oh is this as the tide turned
is everything different now mo Ranger
made them think that a little bit too
because they're like oh this is just how
we do it we make this movie it isn't
very good but we're gonna sell it to
them and they're gonna eat it up and
then it did badly and they were like oh
wow they're paying attention now if
x-men Days of Future past is like bigger
than what we think it is if that becomes
the biggest movie of the summer I will
be completely shocked guys one thing's
for certain I really like talking about
movies with you
yeah totally what did you think about
our pics do you have a list that's more
accurate than ours are you seeing into
the future
leave your list in the comment section
below check out the rules in the
description and maybe you will win two
screen junkies t-shirts that's right one
for you one for your dog and you can
walk them through the neighborhood or
just you know you can wash your car with
the other shirt whatever you'll win two
shirts I want to thank my awesome panel
Kristian harloff Erin Robinson Devin
Faraci you guys brought the pain I want
to thank you for bringing the pain and
watching our show hit me up on Twitter
I'm Hal Rudnick my bike he needs Mutant
Ninja Turtles to the secret of the ooze
it's like 90s product placement totally
pick vanilla ice in the scene you
choreograph a fight to the music with
the Turtles